This is the Steve Young
you most likely remember.
He was a defining athlete
of his generation,
building a career out
of defying expectations.
From being eighth on the BYU depth chart,
to a record USFL contract,
to sitting behind the great
Joe Montana for years,
Young ultimately became a Hall
of Fame, Super Bowl winning
quarterback.
Known for his pinpoint passing accuracy,
and a penchant for dynamic runs.
Trouble, he's gonna be
sacked, no, gets away!
He runs, gets away again!
To the 35, to the 20, to the 15, the ten.
He dives, touchdown 49ers.
I played 18 seasons.
There's a few that have played more.
Tom Brady's now 23, but I got as many
as maybe anyone who ever played.
And I still did have half of my life,
that I wanted to be productive.
And what could you do with
another half of a life?
Turns out, a lot.
Steve Young didn't just make
a name and a fortune from his NFL days.
Armed with a law degree earned
while he was still a player
and a front row seat
to the tech revolution in Silicon Valley,
he's quietly built in an
investment firm that's done
more than $50 billion in deals
over the past two decades.
I mean, look, my previous
life, it was amazing.
You know, throwing Jerry Rice a touch down
in front of 80,000
people and winning games.
Like there's nothing like it.
It's not 80,000 people watching
it, but it feels familiar.
And I think that's why there
is magic in private equity.
This is the Steve Young many haven't seen:
the player turned investor.
I recently got to spend a few days
trying to keep up with Young,
from his offices in Silicon
Valley to a Scottsdale golf club
and lots of places in between.
What started as a straightforward
story about an athlete's
successful transition to business,
turned out to be something much more.
The tale of a relentless guy
intent on finally marrying his
playing and investing careers
with an eye toward radically changing
both deal making and athletes
lives in the process.
Hi.
This is tough decision,
but I know that I've made the right one,
and I really feel it in my
heart and I can't deny it.
And so I retire from the
great game of football today.
Lots of players have managed to move
from the locker room to the boardroom,
taking largely titular roles
as advisors and rainmakers
to companies or investment firms.
Few can say they've committed
as much as Steve Young,
studying investment memos
the same way he studied
the Niners playbook.
All right, dental?
Pat?
You're on your horse.
Young's firm, HGGC sits
in one of the most fascinating
corners of Wall Street,
private equity.
Once upon a time, that
industry was relatively hidden.
Now it's one of the
most influential engines
of the global economy.
It feels like anecdotally,
I'm hearing more like,
oh, private equity,
consolidated, this practice...
Talking about acquiring dental practices
may not be as captivating
as throwing game-winning touchdowns,
but it's a fast growing
very lucrative business.
Collectively, private equity firms
control more than $6 trillion in assets,
according to McKenzie.
The founders of the biggest firms,
guys like Henry Kravis
and Steve Schwartzman,
they are billionaires many times over.
So let's talk for a minute
about the basics of private equity.
Think of it like buying
and selling houses.
Basically, PE firms use a
mix of cash from investors
and money borrowed from banks
to buy companies, make
them more profitable,
and sell them down the line.
And just like with houses,
some people own them for a few years,
take really good care of them,
and sell them for a nice profit.
Others, they're more like flippers,
who look to do the minimum
to make a quick buck.
Buyout firms have been rightly
criticized over the years
for shuttering plants and cutting jobs
in pursuit of those massive profits.
Especially in recent years,
when it comes to medical practices
owned by private equity firms.
Some practitioners have complained
that it forces them to choose
between profits and patients.
So as they've grown in stature,
so too has the scrutiny,
and the sense of responsibility
beyond the bottom line.
Young and his partners,
they're more than cognizant
of that historical reputation.
And they're aiming to be more
nurturing than swashbuckling.
They're operating at a smaller scale
than the big firms in the
so-called middle market,
buying companies worth $50
million to $500 million.
That's still a pretty big business.
HGGC, they've raised four funds,
totaling almost $7 billion.
For Steve Young, it's unquestionably
one of the most successful
second acts of any former athlete.
And while Steve may live
in the same neighborhood in Silicon Valley
as Mark Zuckerberg,
you might not know it from his ride.
Vans are the best cars on the road.
If you don't have a van and you have kids,
and you don't have a van, you're an idiot.
Yeah.
I mean, how do you not go 14
cup holders and six outlets?
I can run everything right
here, it's like a rocket ship.
87 was when I lived here.
Yeah.
I moved here for the first time.
Silicon Valley was kind of up
to full speed in ten years.
So by 1997.
Yeah.
So in the last 20 years
or so, 25 years even,
it's changed in that the
biggest companies in the world
that weren't here 20
years ago are now here.
Right.
But what hasn't changed is
Stanford's down the street.
Silicon Valley's always been
kind of a entrepreneurial place.
Back when Steve was playing
in the early nineties,
the technology boom was
really just cranking up,
just a few miles from where the 49ers
played at Candlestick Park.
We're watching Silicon Valley
just explode around us in Santa Clara.
ThreeCom, Cisco, name any
business, any big business.
And I don't know who had the first idea.
I can't give it to anybody,
'cause I don't know who said it.
Was like, let's bring
'em in the locker room
and we'll tell 'em look,
we'll trade some access
to the locker room,
'cause that's what we have.
Right.
'Cause everyone wanted that, right?
The 49ers at that time?
Yeah.
It'd be like right now who name it?
Like the Patriots or the
Warriors, the Rams or anyone else.
And so we had ten, 15 different companies,
$10,000, $15,000 each, we split it all up,
and that we just started
to come pretty regularly.
Those investments and relationships
were critical for Steve's own transition
into the world of investing,
but access to money
and deals while playing
isn't a guarantee of financial success.
Going into private
equity was a windy road.
When you're playing, you're
one of the best in the world,
or best athletes in the world,
but you don't have financial literacy.
But you have all this money.
Yeah.
And so there's a big, huge chasm
in between your financial literacy
and the money that's in the bank.
We've watched those stories
and the tragic stories.
Yeah.
It was a painful moment
because when you have somebody coming
and trying to take your Rose Bowl rings,
your trophies, your cars, your house.
Redskin's running back Clinton Portis
earning more than $40
million on the gridiron,
but life after football led to bankruptcy
and almost drove him to murder.
Around 15% of NFL players
filed for bankruptcy
within 25 years of retirement.
And while there are extreme
examples of failure and success,
every player has the same transition.
For me, it started when
I first got here in '93,
'cause I wasn't drafted.
So being, you know, kind of coming in,
it was like every day
could be my last day.
While Junior Bryant played
for ten seasons in the NFL,
his transition was sudden.
While making a tackle,
Junior went airborne,
landing with this full weight on his head.
Most careers kind of end
like mine, unfortunately.
It's just the nature of the game.
And even though I was doing all that work
from the very first day,
I still wasn't ready.
I kind of really wandered for a few years.
I had ideas of things I wanted to do.
But I just didn't take the step,
just to kind of move forward.
I had the same paralysis.
Like what exactly am I gonna do?
What am I even qualified to do?
Junior would eventually end
up working at HGGC with Steve,
as well as serve on the board
for his foundation Forever Young.
Through his foundation Forever Young,
Steve is looking to bridge that gap
between athletes having a lot of money,
and as he describes, financial literacy.
He hopes to create a repository
of player transition stories.
It's a resource for players by players
to give unbiased advice on
what comes after sports.
An effort to pay forward
his success off the field
and help others transition
from the field to executive suites,
like the one his firm
has at Levi's Stadium.
Right, so this is the suite.
This is the firm suite.
This is the suite.
Playing the game, and
what we all been through,
players don't realize
how useful that can be
if you paid attention,
They don't realize the
resource that they can be.
As Junior said, we're all kind of frozen.
And I want 'em to know,
by definition of what you've been through,
you have something to
add to the conversation.
I began preparing for my
future beyond football
probably earlier than I wanted to,
because my dad kept pecking at
me about the rest of my life.
What are you gonna do?
What's your plan, what's
your plan, what's your plan?
And I was like, my plan
is to play football.
And he is like, that's not a plan.
That motivation pushed
Steve to go back to school
at the same time he was playing,
running from Super Bowls to
law school for six years.
In 1994, the same year he was league MVP,
he also graduated with a law
degree from Brigham Young.
Without the law degree,
I wouldn't have been able
to get the opportunity
to get into direct investing.
Now, did I have the MBA that
everyone had out of Harvard?
Did I do the four years
of consulting or banking?
No, but I think I was
given the opportunity
because I had that in my pocket.
I wouldn't have gone to law school
if my dad had not driven it in my head
that you better have a plan.
As his professional career wound down,
he would use those relationships
forged in the locker room
to find ways into the world of business.
He sat on the board of Power Bar
after becoming a huge fan
of the product as a player.
He used to just down
them on the sidelines,
Like Niners teammates Ronnie
Lott and Harris Barton,
Young had become more
invested in investing.
He initially formed Northgate Capital
with some ex teammates,
and then went on to Sorenson Capital,
where he first worked with his
future partner, Rich Lawson.
I actually started my
career at Morgan Stanley,
prior to business school,
in the mergers and
acquisitions department,
and slept under a desk in New York
and in Tokyo, Japan for Morgan Stanley.
We had started as direct investors
at a firm called Sorenson Capital,
and that was probably 20 years ago.
The two eventually decided
to create their own firm
alongside two high caliber,
private equity mentors,
Bob Gay and John Huntsman Sr.
What looked like a winning partnership
among the four of them,
initially called Huntsman Gay
Global Capital, didn't last.
Gay opted to take a job
with the Mormon Church
and Huntsman, who planned to join
after his company was
bought, never joined,
when that deal to sell
his company fell through.
So no Huntsman, no Gay,
but Young and Lawson
opted to press ahead as HGGC.
So this is the inner sanctum.
I like it.
We did not clean it up for you.
I apologize, this is a working day.
That's great, and I do, I love the helmet.
The firm's offices are filled
with sports memorabilia,
much of which is used for
prizes and charity work
that Steve and the firm
participate in year round.
But Steve is quick to point out
that it took a while for him to embrace
being surrounded by his past.
When I retired from football,
Roger Staubach was my hero,
and we developed a relationship,
and I asked him, Roger,
you are one of the
greatest transition guys
in the history of the NFL,
to go do something else.
Give me some tips.
And his number one tip was run.
And I go, run, what do you mean run?
He goes, just get it, run, away.
Yeah.
And but he said, because
it'll never leave you.
You'll always have football
and the history in the NFL
and all the things that
happened, but you need to run.
You also, and I don't
think this is a stretch,
had some hesitation about
being ex-football player investor.
You wanted to be an investor.
Is that fair?
That's very fair.
And I think the more
famous you are as a player,
the more accomplished you are,
the more I thought the difficulty would be
to actually have people
take you seriously.
And I wanted my fame to be a tool.
I didn't want it to be a weapon,
and it's so easy to weaponize, right?
You can bring in and just slay the room,
and that's not the way I wanted to do it.
But certainly when I started,
I held myself back in some ways.
So integral to that transition
as it were, that evolution,
is Rich Lawson, your partner.
And we actually, I talked to him last week
about this very topic.
So I wanna show you something,
All right.
His take on it.
Bring some drama.
We have a very long hallway
leading to our shared office,
and I can't seem to get my own wall.
And every week I would put up his jerseys
from his various different accolades,
the USFL or the 49ers or BYU.
And it would be strange because
one day they'd be there,
and then I would come back from a trip
and they'd all be gone.
So I think for years he wanted to minimize
what his past was, as
opposed to embrace it.
It's been really critical to our business.
It's given us a bit of a
defining characteristic
in addition to being good investors,
because no matter how successful
you are in other venues,
if you're not delivering great
returns for your investors,
it doesn't matter.
All true, every bit of it.
I'll call it immaturity on my part,
but it was born out of this
desire to try to make sure
that what I was doing,
I wanted people to know
I was serious about.
And that meant grinding it out on deals,
doing the work to find,
buy, and fix companies.
HGGC has completed more than
500 portfolio investments,
transactions with an enterprise
value of nearly $50 billion.
Young and Lawson's playbook?
It's one of cultivating
relationships over long periods
to consummate deals.
As time went on, the sports memorabilia
and Wall Street deal toys,
those lucite mementos of companies
bought and sold and taken
public, began to share space.
You can see the 49er room
is the main conference room.
Okay, we get it.
Someone joked, I said, we
promise to put you over Joe
is the only place I ever get.
It's funny,
where I was sneaking
around your office earlier,
I saw that picture of you and Montana.
Very intimate portrait.
We all agree that it was awkward.
It never wasn't awkward.
In fact, AT&T did a
commercial on it recently.
Exactly.
But it was always profitable.
And I think that was that creative tension
that had in a part of it.
And I'll always honor my time with Joe.
I hated watching, but
I loved watching Joe.
Do you think about that in the context
of like business and CEOs
and succession, like.
Oh, hundred percent.
You've got to, right?
So much of this business
is classic relationship.
A few days later, I joined Steve
at his charity golf
tournament at Troon North,
just outside of Scottsdale, Arizona.
The proceeds of that day
go to his philanthropic
organization Forever Young.
For nearly three decades,
that's served children
facing significant physical,
emotional, and financial challenges.
I love golf, I love thinking about it.
I just don't play it very often,
but I believe that if you love golf
and you don't play very often,
you can get better kind
of in your backyard.
That's my theory, and
it has proven untrue.
Steve's ability on the course
may not be etched into any record books,
but following him around all day,
it's clear that it's
not for lack of trying.
Oh well.
All right, off we go.
We were constantly hustling behind him
as he caught up with executives
in the portfolio companies
and reminisced with former
and current players.
He's a day trader.
He taught himself, self-made day trader.
And so he's on the bus
after a game in New England,
and he's day trading on the bus,
and Bill Belichick sees him
and cuts him on the spot.
The season that they
went to the Super Bowl,
day trading got him cut.
You know, in many ways
it's a convention, right,
Of the people that I don't
see, maybe once a year,
we're half the field or more
from our own portfolio in our own firm.
And so it's kind of all come together.
My firm, our charity,
our fundraising efforts,
and then the friends that are
around, my dad and my brother,
it's all happens right there
as a confluence of all
these parts of my life
that have found its common center.
You should meet Andy.
This is Andy in the black hat here.
He's a CEO.
It may sound trite,
but these personal
relationships and conversations
that Steve has with
folks on the golf course,
it's actually similar
to his and the firm's
approach to private equity.
For them, the art is in the relationships
built across the negotiating table.
And even in the days, months, decades
leading up to being at that table,
rather than Excel based financial models
ground out by young analysts
in Manhattan skyscrapers
more typically associated
with buyout firms.
If you could leave the hubris behind,
that says, I love that business,
but it would be so much
better if I ran it, right.
To me, the more profitable way to do it,
not just in returns,
but in kind of legacy,
in abundance,
is to approach it kind of looking at
the person across the table
as your strategic partner.
Help me understand how
you fit into the family?
One of HGGC's best partnerships
was with Brian Adams,
the founder and CEO of an
insurance technology company
called Integrity.
Well, so we had an advisor
that linked us up in the beginning,
and you know, the first thing,
everybody thinks of Steve
as a football player,
and you're intimidated by this idea
of this Hall of Fame quarterback.
But what you really see quickly
is how humble Steve is, how normal he is.
Integrity is part of an auction in 2016,
one where 19 others were bidding.
And while HGGC didn't put up
the highest monetary offer,
it was the relationship that
Steve had struck up with Brian
that helped them win the deal.
Steve and I got to know each other
and got to become friends.
And we started really kind
of aligning our values.
For us, it was a lot of this
kind of value alignment.
It was like, we've got to figure
out how to become partners.
And it's been an incredible rise for us.
After HGGC took a minority
stake in Integrity,
Steve was appointed chairman of the board.
In six years, the company grew
from a few hundred employees
to more than 5,000.
That's in large part due
to acquiring 125 companies
through M and A.
Most recently Integrity
got a new round of funding,
$1.2 billion from Silver Lake,
one of the biggest firms out there.
They returned the fund and more,
with one, just one investment
off of a faith and a relationship,
really more than anything.
And a belief in each other.
Integrity is also an interesting example
of something notable, and
again, somewhat radical
that you do around
compensation and ownership,
and something that you've
extended that idea,
even into your own firm
in a different way.
That's right.
So walk me through that.
Brian had the idea that,
he had 3000 employees at the time,
and you know what?
The equity owners of the business,
the people that have the stock,
are making incredible amounts of money,
but the employees are
getting paid their salaries.
What if we gave them stock?
In 2019, Integrity would do something
almost unheard of for a company
of their size and potential.
They distributed partial
ownership in the company
to their employee base.
He did that as a private business,
and I thought that's a way to solve
for a lot of the ills of corporate world
and how people see the world,
as building equity
inside the employee base.
And I loved that,
and I think we've done
it in our firm as well.
And kind of more distributed partnership
and trying to give equity out.
Ownership, not just held by two people,
because what that does
is it allows for generational mindset.
Steve's work with growing
players into business people
mirrors the work he's
doing at his own firm.
There, he and Lawson are nurturing
the next generation of investors at HGGC.
And they're thinking of
how his legacy will live on
in the world of private equity,
through those younger executives.
This is a place
where there are 25ish
investment professionals,
and every single one of us
is welcome to bring
our ideas to the table.
And those ideas are heard.
So we meet every Friday
for investment committee,
and it's not just the
investment committee.
It's not the five or
ten partners that meet,
it's the entire firm.
And a lot of places, that's not the case.
Good friend ran a famous
private equity firm nearby.
And he said, your culture
is what I want our firm to be like?
Well, what do you do?
I said, well, the first
thing you gotta do,
is your founders need to put
all of their relationships in the middle
and no one owns anything.
And you don't fight over
those relationships.
They're the firm's.
15 seconds, and he's like,
yeah, that's not gonna work.
He's like, uh, I'm out.
So it's like, the culture has
to be kind of in the roots,
and that resonates with people.
Passing down this spirit of abundance
approach to private equity,
all came from Steve's playing days,
and his Hall of Fame coach, Bill Walsh.
I watched him do it in the late eighties.
There's a guy with a
camera, the old school,
you know, big thing of on his back
and he'd follow Bill around everywhere.
Filming Bill as he spoke to the team,
went out on the practice field,
installed the offense, in the lunchroom.
And I kept asking, what is this,
like a museum they're doing?
Or what are they doing,
a special documentary?
Like, no one knew.
Well, what it was,
was that he was creating
a physical toolkit
of video based, audio
based, of all his speeches,
and all of his playbooks and
all of his installations,
everything paper based that he had,
and essentially wrapping
it all up as a toolkit
to hand it to his assistant coaches,
that he wanted to go have
success in the league.
Who takes all their secrets,
all the things that makes them great
at the height of their greatness,
three or four generations ahead
of everybody else in the league,
and wraps it up and hands it
to the people who are leaving
to go coach other places
and then says to them,
you know what, I'll see you
in the championship game.
And it happened.
There's a spirit to legacy.
There's a spirit to...
And so I watched it and I said to him,
Bill, why would you do that?
And he said, Steve, we've
got to give opportunity.
I want these men to succeed.
And I thought, that's
a heck of a statement,
'cause of course you do,
but who does the actual work
to give them the opportunity to go succeed
and giving away what you
own that is most valuable?
Is that great business?
You can make an argument
that maybe that is the great
business that we need to be in.